hello whoever you are and wherever you
came from and welcome to your future now
you're probably wondering where exactly
you are and who exactly we are
unfortunately that's not something we
can tell you at this point the purpose
of this short educational video is to
inform you and your fellow inductees
what you should expect from your new
life here at the foundation first of all
you will be given a unique personal
identification number tattoo directly
onto your chest your colleagues will be
referred to henceforward
as Class D the D stands for delightful
now that you are equipped with your new
identity what's next well this is where
the fun begins
let's talk fashion say goodbye to your
boring old clothes with our super
comfortable standard-issue electric
orange overalls to keep you warm and
cozy now performing your assigned
responsibilities all the while keeping
you looking fresh and professional
speaking of responsibilities let's talk
about your purpose here is to
accommodate your supervisors demands
those are the friendly guys with the
guns such as cleaning up nasty message
interacting with interesting characters
don't go off script making sure you're
ready tip-top shape
the infirmary is always open and
fulfilling interdepartmental deliveries
and much much more you couldn't ask
these four simple points and your time
here will be a walk in the park number
one a locked door is a happy door number
two questions are bad
number three supervisor satisfaction is
key and finally number four no pain no
gain but it doesn't end here if you
successfully complete one month of
rigorous class D work wait for it you
get to go home no strings attached you
are free
I'd say feel free to come back and visit
anytime but we can't tell you where we
are so what are you waiting for get out
there and make us proud like your life
depends on it thank you for listening
goodbye and most importantly good luck
[Music]
you
you